i know that you did this on stage but
even then i mean when you sign on to do
a retelling of something like cyrano
that so many people are familiar with
and it's been told so many times
is there a sense of relief in knowing
that
that it's a story that's been around for
so long or do you get extra nervous
about
bringing something new to a story that's
been around for so long
i guess at a certain point
you just have to you know you have to
let that let let that go and kind of
you know connect with the material
uh
on a personal level and and try to um
you know tell the story as truthfully as
possible um
and you know as an actor whatever that
whatever that means to you
um and i'm you know i'm really grateful
to to erica you know we we'd made this
uh
as a this adaptation as a stage play
first
um and i'm so grateful to pete and eric
for embracing my interpretation of the
character
um
but of course yeah yeah there there
definitely is there's definitely
pressure but you know with the film joe
had such a you know a specific vision
for the piece and and it's it's um
it's a it's a film that's set in the
fantasy world of a period
rather than you know you know it's not
so glued to the original
story um which is set in france
obviously which it is a french story
but the characters exist in an alluring
dream world of a reality and it's a
drama but we also sing in the film so
there's a lot of
elements um
that are completely new
from how moving your performance is to
the emotion that comes out in the songs
i can't imagine anyone else playing
roxanne but you've also said that you
weren't sure if you would get to do this
so
how hard was the waiting to find out
well i was eight months pregnant when
when we finished the stage production at
the good speed theater which was a 70 uh
70
70 per 70 person theater
it sat 70 people yeah
and um and you know when i first sought
out to to do theater you know i'd always
dreamed of getting to go you know
you know maybe one day performing on
broadway or off broadway or
you know any theater would would be fine
but then it did it transferred to
broadway but when we finished the play i
was eight months pregnant with my
daughter
um
playing a virgin which
i don't know how successfully i did that
but but i was really gutted when i when
i
when i didn't get to to go off broadway
um but i had been offered a part in ron
howard's film and that was just much
more practical in terms of um
you know nurturing a a a new
relationship with with uh with with with
my with my newborn um and but i felt
like i just wasn't finished with with
the project but i you know at the same
time i knew that joe was
um
was
developing the project for the screen um
uh to make the film with erica uh pete's
wife who was
um writing the script for um for the
film
but you know that's a really long and
drawn out process and you know you never
know if films are going to get made or
if they're not and you know i knew i
knew that
you know the casting of pete would be
set in stone but but i'd you know i
didn't know that that uh that for sure
the you know the studio would approve my
casting what was it like to have the
familiarity of collaborating with peter
dinklage but the discovery of
collaborating with kelvin harrison i
what did you enjoy about sort of being
caught between the two of them as scene
partners i mean one of my favorite
scenes that i got to take part in was
the balcony scene where we all
were together in in one scene and it's
such a um
exciting scene for an actor um
uh there's there's such a fine balance
between you know what what roxanne is
aware of and what she isn't aware of and
and and i loved kind of that dynamic
between um with peter and and i i mean i
had to stop myself from laughing
um many times between like
during takes because i i just you know
they're both so dynamic and talented and
enigmatic and but it was kind of like
you know christian is
uh the puppet and and and um
and sierna was the puppeteer and you
know i
i loved kind of uh the way that calvin
his his um
his physicality that he used and that
scene and kind of he'd be talking you
know
he would be expressing himself even
though he wasn't the one saying the
words i i really love the kind of how
nuanced of a performance that um kelvin
gave in that scene
did you have a favorite song that you've
got to perform in this
um
yeah definitely i think it's i need more
uh because it's just a real it felt like
a real power ballad is also the song
that i was most afraid of
um because you know i had to reach such
great heights with with the with the
notes and
and and being that we
had to sing it live but also i think you
know it's one of the most liberating um
songs to perform
because uh you know i
i set out and i set out an intention to
not try to sound
good like i was like okay if i sound
ugly if i sound hideous if i don't hit a
note that's okay you know i i really i
wanted to free myself from those
expectations and i felt like maybe that
would make for a more interesting
performance of like rather
you know
you know
um and and and i and i loved it too
because you know i had all of this space
um to inhabit into like all of this
space to take up and i was like
i really enjoyed um and and relished in
taking up that much space
um
and it's not something
i feel like as an actor i've i've had
the chance to do
um and
i
i absolutely loved it
well i appreciate you talking to me
about it i love the strength and the
independence that this character has i
think she it just it's such a beautiful
character so thank you for talking about
her and the film
you